va bene io l'ho già detto e mi chiamo
anna gaia e sono un'attrice sono veneta
sono lesbica e sono sempre stata
discriminata perché sono veneta
questa è quindi io in realtà oggi vorrei
parlare un po di discriminazione e
paradossalmente mi collego a questo
bellissimo intervento perché la
discriminazione parte dalle parole no ed
è una cosa su cui sto da molto tempo
riflettendo come ci stava dicendo
appunto i greci dicevano che noi non
conosciamo le cose ma sono le cose che
sappiamo nominare e quindi è per questo
che i geologi hanno un sacco di parole
per le rocce gli eschimesi per il
ghiaccio e i veneti almeno cinque tipi
di spritz noi i bambini non riescono a
dire io fino ai tre anni perché non
sanno che cos'è yo yo da brava veneta
imparato prima dire spritz per esempio e
quando sono riuscito a dire io la mia
identità non era fondato sul fatto che è
una bambina che aveva la pelle bianca o
chiaro italiana o veneta io potevo anche
essere un gufo ed essere verde per me e
la mia identità era legata a tutti
quelli che andavano a scuola materna
contro tutti quelli che potevano
mangiare dormire fino alle 11 e poi
quando ho capito il noi per me il noi è
arrivato verso i nove anni perché andavo
al mare eravamo il gruppo del mare
eravamo un gruppo di dieci le varietà
che si ritrovavano in una località
dell'adriatico sottomarina lido chi è
veramente eravamo c'è solo noi 10 tutto
il mondo perché più che altro tutto il
mondo se ne fotte vari sottomarina lido
era un luogo totalmente inquinato che
già negli anni 90 i pescatori erano
vegetariani quindi quando uno andava in
acqua diceva addio e moriva eravamo gli
unici bambini che i genitori mandavano a
fare il bagno anche subito dopo mangiato
perché dicevano vabbè tanto more guai
per me ecco quella era la mia patria era
il noi e dare luogo più bello del mondo
in questo senso le parole determina le
cose per esempio per esempio la parola
straniero
io la prima volta che l'ho sentita avrò
avuto 10 anni in questa escalation di
conoscenza dell'universo ed è stata mia
nonna a dirmelo
mi ha raccontato che un giorno lei in
bicicletta mia nonna
la bennet ha chiaramente di mira questo
paese invece andava in giro per mira si
è scontrata contro un vecchietto di un
paese vicino mira porte sono finiti uno
sopra l'altro con le bici sopra di loro
questi due ottantenni incapaci di
muoversi
momenti di panico in attesa che qualcuno
li aiutasse a raccogliersi mia nonna gli
dice
scusa ma da dove seo e lo è il
vecchietto rispondetemi sode mila porte
e mia nonna e non poteva starsene casa
sua straniero così è stato chiaro che
nella vita insomma bisogna sempre
scendere nelle barricate che tra l'altro
veneto le barricate sono solo di grappa
è invece la prima volta che ho sentito
la parola lesbica
avevo 16 anni e stavo facendo il gioco
della bottiglia è un certo punto alla
bottiglia si ferma su di me e poi sulla
più bella della scuola che si chiamava
manuela e allora uno dice eh no però non
la puoi baciare perché sennò vuol dire
che sei lesbica
io che sono un ipocondriaca pensa una
malattia mortale svengo manuela che
faceva lo psico pedagogico che è una
cosa veramente anni 90 psicopedagogico
aveva dei rudimenti di primo soccorso
quindi mi fa la respirazione bocca a
bocca
io rinvengo e vengo varie volte però
chiaramente nel dubbio quella sera vado
a casa dalla mia mia confidente
personale che è la mia nonna diceva
nonna ma scusa ma secondo te io sono
lesbica io non ho fanon amore tu sei
solo un poco presbite però ho capito in
quell'occasione che se la parola lesbica
veniva usata male poteva essere un
insulto eppure io in quell'occasione
avevo conosciuto il desiderio il
desiderare non si dice come raggiungere
le stelle con manuela è per questo che
quando noi usiamo delle parole per le
parole noi dobbiamo avere rispetto
no che me letteralmente rispettare vuol
dire guardare due volte guardare meglio
io non vi dico quanto ho rispettato
manuela tantissimo e soprattutto perché
ho capitoli che la mia vita fino a quel
punto era stata una vita in bianco e
nero
l'amore mi ha fatto scoprire una vita
colori e l'amore tutti provano le stesse
gioie gli stessi dolori e proprio una
legge che a differenza della legge è
uguale per tutti e in questo senso
conquistare le parole e conquistare le
cose non necessariamente conquistare
manuela comunque ci tengo a specificarlo
negli anni no il movimento quello che si
parlava prima il movimento lgbt ha
conquistato una serie di parole la mia
preferita
non è una parola è un simbolo è il più
non so se avete sentito ultimamente si
parla lgbt q più più vuol dire tutti gli
altri che secondo una cosa geniale c'è
noi siamo la prima minoranza che
comprende una moltitudine cavina e la
cosa divertente è che la moltitudine non
sa neanche che fa parte del nostro
movimento e questa è la cosa più geniale
di tutte che io perché poi c'è ma
veramente sembrano avere assurdo ma è
così che voglio dire adesso noi siamo
avvicinati sono solo la situazione a
pavia però a milano dove le persone sono
libere di sentirsi di essere quello che
gli pare
io veramente di estero sessuali non ne
conosco quasi in una cosa è vero e non
ce ne sono ma veramente c'è escono e
sabato sera col passamontagna non sono
terroristi sono eterosessuali libera
uscita
hanno paura che li riconoscono
dall'ufficio io mi sono rimaste due
amiche etero due sono rimaste etero
davvero mi chiamano sabato sera
piangendo disperata e una mela sono
anche fatta non ti spaventare adesso ci
sei anche tu nel movimento è capito c'è
anche il più lgbt q più ma perché poi
c'è questo chiuda cosa c'è l'importante
no perché è importante che ci siamo
tutti dentro a questo movimento perché
al movimento che parla dell'identità e
nostra identità e mutamento in
trasformazione e tra queste parole che
riguardano il mood e mutamento della
trasformazione c'è la parola gender no
adesso c'è questa il gender allora io vi
dico la prima volta che ho sentito la
parola gender sarà stata cinque anni fa
ero in tournée nelle marche a civitanova
marche e fuori da un palazzo c'era uno
striscione con scritto più gender meno
gengiviti va beh io penso sarà una roba
un collutorio della zona così mettiamo
la passano gli anni
tre anni fa sarà stato più o meno
improvvisamente una mattina io so cosa è
successo quella sera
ma una mattina a tutti parlavano del
gender tutti tutti avevano un opinione
del gender che dico quando se la sono
fatta nella notte non e io pensavo ma
che cazzo di problema c'hanno le persone
con civitanova marche che poi c'è
breaking news gender vuol dire solo
genere in inglese
e tu dici ma perché noi italiani siamo
così c'è prima era solo una parola poi è
diventata in inglese una teoria e non è
successo niente non è cambia non
esisterà teoria gente perché non è una
teoria di genere non esiste ce ne sono
molteplici
quindi quando qualcuno mi dice che ha un
problema con la teoria del gender
l'unico problema che ha e di
informazione no è grave però perché poi
è su questo che si originano altre cose
nel senso che la teoria gender è servita
per gettare discredito su altre parole
per esempio la parola famiglia che
potrebbe essere inclusiva quando è
diventata famiglie arcobaleno con la the
origin da è diventato che le famiglie
arcobaleno per esempio non esistono
no abbiamo sentito quindi per lungo
tempo mi sono chiesta c'è ma se noi non
esistiamo e le tasse le paghiamo non le
paghiamo perché io me la risposta è no
questa cosa no oppure qualcuno dice no
agli omosessuali per esempio distruggono
le famiglie cioè allora magari qualcuno
pensa che non abbiamo veramente niente
da fare che aspettiamo dietro gli angoli
delle porte che passino le famiglie
eterosessuali coi figli per fare però
questo chiaramente genera delle parole
di odio per esempio a me una persona una
signora mi ha scritto su facebook c'era
una foto di me con la mia ex fidanzata
che ci baciavamo e scrivere ma che
schifo come fai a baciarla fate schifo e
poi non che la vedono i bambini e poi
siete anche grasse e ho detto
[Applauso]
allora c'era scritto guardia
cortesemente sa lei mi dice dove vive io
vengo quelle a parlarne in maniera tu
per tu anche perché tra l'altro mi
sembrava veramente incredibile che
potessi parlare con qualcuno della mia
ex
finalmente è comunque ha detto guardi
tra l'altro se non me lo dice comunque
lo scoprirò perché oltre a essere
un'attrice essere disoccupata sono anche
single ora e quindi però però ovviamente
quindi cosa succede il termine famiglia
un termine una parola da conquistare
famiglia nel senso che noi abbiamo
grandissimi sovrastrutture su questa
parola perché la mulino bianco ha fatto
dei danni inenarrabili e quindi io
quando ho cercato di capirci qualcosa
sul termine famiglia la prima cosa che
ho fatto è stato chiederla mia nonna che
aveva la famiglia famosa famiglia
patriarcale di una volta no allora
chiedo a mia nonna di parlarmi della sua
famiglia erano otto fratelli giusta una
volta erano otto fratelli contrae dei
quali non si parlano più per ragioni
sconosciute a loro stessi poi c'era la
zia pina la zia tina aveva avuto un
bambino di colore dopo la guerra e per
guarirlo si era trasferita in piemonte
malattia incurabile perché il bambino
era rimasto di colore è particolarmente
portato per l'inglese americano poi
c'era la zia adelaide pazzi adelaide era
di una bruttezza rara ma cuccava da dio
non si sa come e lei era fanatica della
famiglia dei bortolotti si era fatta
tutti e tre i fratelli e poi aveva
sposato il più giovane che si chiamava
ultimo che veneti sono fantasiosi cave
così lui era morto trent'anni prima di
lei e lei si era sposata con un cugino
dello zio ultimo perché lui era ultimo
ma non l'ultimo dei bortolotti estate
che una volta un tizio per farsela detto
che era un bortolotti lei nel dubbio c'è
stata
no poi c'era mia nonna questo quadro
familiare
poi c'era lo zio nino che lui
e stato scapolo fino al 75 anni e quindi
se lo passavano le varie sorelle che
immagino voi lo capiate una volta si
chiamavano scapoli
adesso si chiamano gay lui è evidente
che era gay scavi va anche dalle foto
anche se loro non volevano accettarlo ci
sono proprio quei gay che si vede dalla
foto che sono gay
cioè il mio migliore amico sulla carta
d'identità è messa così
e poi c'era mia nonna mia nonna e la zia
maria la più giovane di tutte
perdutamente innamorata di un prete per
cui ha fatto la perpetua per 70 anni
della sua vita
temo per entrambi senza consumare perché
l'amore è amore ma quella era una
famiglia timorata di dio
poi sono arrivata io con la mia famiglia
mia mamma sia sposata avuto un unica
figlia i miei genitori sono due persone
particolari si amano da 45 anni
una cosa rarissima è però avendo solo me
come figlia
ovviamente erano due persone molto
apprensive ha quindi loro per
fortificarmi per dire mi gettavano in
acqua senza salvagente e mi salvano solo
all'ultimo
io non ho mai imparato a nuotare ma ho
capito molto presto cosa significa
probabilmente morire e questo
chiaramente ha segnato la mia vita
futura allora questa queste sono le
varie storie delle famiglie
dopo di che cosa cosa succede una
famiglia composta da due donne e niente
è una famiglia come dire uguale diversa
da tutte le altre certo ci sono delle
differenze non è che io non dico che non
ci siano delle differenze per dire se
entra in casa uno scarafaggio nella
famiglia eterosessuale lo sai come
funziona
lei dice lui non fai un cazzo almeno cd
lo scarafaggio però ucciderlo senza
ammazzarlo senza fargli male senza
sporcare perché in una famiglia di due
donne cosa cosa succede entra lo
scarafaggio no una urla l'altra urla poi
una comincia a parlare l'altra comincia
a parlare dopo cinque minuti lo
scarafaggio si è rotto i [ __ ] se ne
va da solo
tra due gay mi hanno detto funziona così
che uno ora l'altro urla e la casa la
vendono però quindi questa sicuramente
una differenza poi certo poi mi dicono
ma chi è che allora tra due tra due
donne quando stanno insieme due donne
chi è che fa il barbecue questo ultimo
residuo di questo avamposto
dell'eterosessualità contemporanea
io non lo so quanti uomini qui fanno il
bar voi fate il barbecue to them il
barbecue momento di confronto importante
che la propria virilità
lei fa il barbecue certo ora non
potevano che avere un esemplare che fa
il barca allora quindi cosa succede a
due lesbiche io veramente io non lo so
che al marmo io mi sono detta forse
quella coi capelli più corti però dico
non è che magari seria bruciati facendo
il barbecue tra due gay fortunatamente
per loro il problema non si pone perché
il barbecue lo usano come portacandele
quindi certo ogni famiglia c'è le sue
dinamiche
non vi dico poi nel pieno di un trasloco
perché un trasloco tra due donne
immaginavo riposato immagine non è un
trasloco è un esodo 400 paia di mutande
400 paia di calze di 400 paia di scarpe
a testa
noi veramente nel piano di trasloco
sembra di vivere nella succursale di
intimissimi il giorno dei saldi che io
quando ho fatto trasloco praticamente
non aiutato quasi nessuno perché c'è
quasi tutti amici gay gay durante un
trasloco accende la radio canta questi
mente sul letto e comincia a dire farai
quando cioe lo fare tesoro è così e
quindi certo queste possono essere delle
differenze sostanziali ma quella più
incredibile di tutte è questa che
proprio noi ai quali qualcuno sostiene
che non siamo delle famiglie visibili o
reali
noi donne siamo in realtà le uniche che
stanno assieme per sempre perché le
donne sono fatte così due donne prima di
lasciarsi ne parlano e passano diversi
anni
durante i quali tornano insieme quindi
in realtà le uniche famiglie destinate a
rimanere nel futuro sono quelle composte
da donne
ed è questo il punto ma il punto e qui
mi chiudo e mi piace moltissimo alla
bennet che diceva ogni famiglia ha un
segreto e il segreto è che non è come le
altre famiglie e quindi per scoprire
qual è la nostra famiglia o quella delle
altre mi ricollego al fatto che possiamo
usare le parole scardinarle e
rivendicarne ogni volta loro la coloro
contestualizzazione e la loro esistenza
perché dentro ad ogni parola si nasconde
il segreto della nostra liberazione
[Applauso]